- [Narrator] For the most
unique and ancient site
in all of Sri Lanka, you'll
need to look up, way, way up.
(lively, bouncy music)
Located 660 feet on top of a rock plateau
in the Matale District of
Sri Lanka, lay the ruins
of a 5th Century fortress
of King Kashyapa.
The shape and size of the rock
jutting out from the jungle
below was created by hardened
lava from an extinct volcano,
which dates back to prehistoric times.
The rock formation has come to be known
by the name, Sigiriya, or Lion Rock,
after the large stone lion
that once marked the entrance
to the staircase.
Visitors climbing to
the top should prepare
for the 1,200 steps it will
take to scale Sigiriya.
To distract from the steep
climb, visitors can study
the 1,500-year-old frescoes
painted all along the rocks.
At the top are the abandoned
remains of the King's fortress,
along with an incredible view
of what are believed to be
some of the oldest landscaped
gardens in the world.
It's a long climb, but once at the top,
you'll be experiencing what
is referred to by locals
as the 8th Wonder of the World.
(bell chiming)